the doors are open so come on in
at midnight rules relaxed this a comedy
gig that just couldn't wait till the
morning
right now in my own head i'm in my own
room and i can finish this gig just by
going
distancing in the rule of six may still
apply indoors
but being back's a relief and a joy i'm
so
giving the idea of seeing people in the
club
welcoming them in you know like there's
something that happens there's a magic
that happens when an audience come
together
and every everybody melts away and
suddenly
your one laugh your one um
kind of consciousness in a way without
sounding too kind of hippie about it
it's just nice to be part of a group
hugging and holidays are also now back
a coming together so many have craved
hello welcome back
at ghetto golf in birmingham they can't
wait for more mixing
like many they relied on a small outdoor
bar
but the key attractions are inside
having customers here
means having staff back to work we've
just
tried to keep our teams motivated
we're just now excited that it's finally
hospitality inside is opening
we can get all of the team back to work
in a safe way
and we're just we're all looking really
looking forward to it but this
is the backdrop and behind calls for
caution
surge testing in towns where the indian
variant is spreading
the prime minister has asked for
responsible enjoyment
how people respond could matter
immensely when it's opened up i'm
letting loose
i don't want to hear about the indian
variant to be honest because
i want it to open up and stay open i
want normality so i'm going to try to be
as normal as possible
but as safe as possible at the same time
and many have much rebuilding to do
empty airports speak volumes about an
industry embattled
cleaning regimes may be second to none
but with most destinations off limits
there's only so much they can do
pre-pandemic heathrow we would serve
around 240
000 passengers a day and during the
pandemic that has absolutely fallen and
in the trough it was less than 10 000
passengers a day
and we can't wait to welcome passengers
back more turbulence is possible but
it's still a step forward
our old lives just maybe in reach helen
and smith sky news